if you have ever stumbled onto one of
those click bait list articles with
titles like world's top 10 smartest
people then you might have seen this
name come up william james sidus his
name is often included in these lists
alongside a claim that his iq is between
250 and 300
for context that is higher than any
recorded result and anything above 140
is considered genius
people like stephen hawking and einstein
are said to have iqs around 160.
now from what i can tell this claim
about william situs's iq seems highly
dubious
in fact i can't find any evidence that
he ever took an iq test
it was his sister who said that a
psychologist had once measured his iq to
be between 250 and 300
but that might have come about from a
misunderstanding or an exaggeration when
william did write to his sister saying
that he had just taken a civil service
exam for which he scored
254th on the list of candidates but he
himself described that as not so
encouraging what is true about william
situs is that he was very intelligent
and he was a child prodigy the new york
times was reporting about him when he
was 10 years old and had just passed the
mit entrance exam
it says that when he was two he could
read and write and when he was four he
could speak four languages what is also
true about william situs is that he has
a very interesting story and i'll share
that story in this video as well as
share some of the work that he left
behind he set the record for the
youngest person to enroll at harvard at
age 11 and at age 12 he gave a lecture
there on four dimensional bodies
william's father boris sidus was a
psychiatrist and his mother sarah was a
doctor they had a lot of thoughts about
developmental psychology and put a lot
of effort into raising william to be a
prodigy they spent any spare money on
books and learning tools for him and
nurtured his hunger for knowledge
william sidus was named after his dad's
friend william james who was a
philosopher and psychologist it was
boris sidus and william james who
together came up with the idea that we
only used 10 percent of our brains
and they tested this theory on young
william when william showed great
talents and learning it was seen as
proof that most people only meet a
fraction of their full mental potential
it was called the reserve energy theory
and boris was trying to unlock his son's
reserve energy this 10 of the brain idea
is largely considered a myth now with
wikipedia saying that it rests in
folklore not science and that brain
mapping suggests that all areas of the
brain have a function and that they are
used nearly all of the time
but keep that reserve energy theory in
your mind because it's important to this
story in unexpected ways life as a child
prodigy wasn't easy for william he was
constantly reported on and struggled to
fit in with older students
both at school and university
after he graduated his degree he told
reporters that he wanted to live the
perfect life which to him meant living
in seclusion he abandoned further
studies in maths and law and even got
arrested for participating in a
political parade
after that incident his parents tried to
reform him but he soon became estranged
from them and went on to live a very
independent and private life he ended up
suing the new yorker for an article they
published about him calling him lonely
and invading his privacy
the sentiment of that article as well as
many modern footnotes about him seem to
imply that despite his great early
promise he amounted to nothing or that
he suffered a complete mental breakdown
due to being pushed too hard mentally as
a child by his parents but in all those
years of william sidus living outside of
the public eye he was still learning and
writing and sharing knowledge he
published many books under pseudonyms
but i have one here that he published
under his own name it is called the
animate and the inanimate and it was
published in 1920 when he was 22.
it details a theory of his that relates
to cosmology physics and life so let's
have a look through it
cytus says that this work is based on
the idea of the reversibility of
everything in time
that is that all of the physical laws
work backwards
but there is one exception and that is
the second law of thermodynamics
the second law relates to the idea that
say you have a bunch of particles in a
box
they might start off all concentrated in
one corner but over time they will
spread out
and it's so extremely unlikely that they
would all collect in that corner again
that we consider it to be impossible
with this we see that the flow of heat
goes from hot to cold you don't see
water spontaneously turning into ice
because this is such an unlikely flow of
energy
insidis mentions the idea of maxwell's
daemon that if you were to have a
reversal of this second law of
thermodynamics that you could imagine a
sorting demon who could separate the
slower particles from the faster ones
the demon could do this by monitoring
some kind of barrier between two halves
of the box
only letting slow particles into the
left-hand side and fast particles into
the right
you'd see that left-hand side of the box
become cold and the right-hand side
become hot something that wouldn't
naturally happen but seems to have made
available some kind of energy flow
between hot and cold
the second law of thermodynamics also
brought in the idea of entropy which is
constantly increasing
and for the next hundred or so pages
william cyrus explores the idea that
perhaps in some regions of space we do
see a reversal of the second law of
thermodynamics and in these regions
entropy flows in the other direction
he also claims that perhaps these
regions are what we know as life that
instead of defining life as something
that is able to reproduce or grow or
respond to the environment
that we instead define it as something
that is able to take what we might have
thought of as unavailable energy
and turn it into a reserve fund of
energy used only by life and created by
non-living forces
and then he mentions the work of his
father's friend professor william james
who discovered in the domain of mental
phenomena what he calls reserve energy
that's that whole 10 of the brain idea
so william situs is taking this idea
that he has been raised to believe in
and that his father was heavily involved
with
and perhaps he credits for the reason he
is called a prodigy and tries to apply
it to physics to thermodynamics and the
laws of the universe he does mention
that this work is purely speculative and
that there are no experiments to verify
what he suggests this work never really
reached an audience and perhaps that
made cytus feel despondent about it and
he didn't publish any more known works
of physics this work was pretty much
unknown until it was rediscovered in an
attic in 1979 but let's take a little
look through some more of the chapters
the first few chapters look at some of
the physical laws and explores what they
might look like in a reverse universe he
says that in the real universe energy
runs down to a common level
and in the reverse universe energy tends
to build itself up into different levels
in the real universe we would see a
ultimate heat death
mentioned here as when all of the energy
is in the form of heat its least
concentrated form and at a uniform
concentration
a dead level of energy would be reached
and after that nothing further could
ever happen in the universe that's
unless heat was able to build itself up
into different levels and be converted
back into mechanical or kinetic energy
as in our reverse universe now i don't
mean to make any of this sound too
believable and there are many dubious
claims in here
we've got here the requirement that the
mechanical efficiency in the reverse
universe is over a hundred percent
just like how the second law of
thermodynamics is really an overwhelming
probability rather than a law so too is
its reversal that in this reverse
universe these probabilities are awaited
in the opposite direction
cytus believes that tracing back there
must be a time in the past when the
available energy was a hundred percent
of the total universe and there must
have been what he called a great
collision where everything was at a
temperature of absolute zero and there
were two semi-universes which were
moving towards each other
in each of which there was not even a
trace of relative motion sidus believes
that in our own universe 50
of cases will obey the second law of
thermodynamics and in 50 of the cases it
will be reversed the universe as a whole
will be neutral
so where apparently is all of this
reverse universe hiding well ciders
believed that there were vast pockets of
space that have a tendency towards the
positive direction
and other pockets that have a tendency
in the reverse direction that the
universe is made up of a number of what
we may call bricks alternately positive
and negative all approximately the same
volume arranged sort of like a
three-dimensional checkerboard that what
we see is simply the white space that we
are in
the black spaces surrounding us are
invisible and then the laws of
thermodynamics would be predominantly
reversed
the stars in those black spaces would be
reverse stars
but instead of giving out light they
absorb light this is an intriguing part
of his discussion because he's doing a
good job of describing what we would now
call black holes
he calls these reverse stars perfectly
black bodies these stars use radiant
energy to build up a higher level of
heat he says that we can only see stars
in the section of space where the second
law of thermodynamics prevails
but that there is an additional part of
the universe which is not visible to us
these black spaces even absorb the light
from the white spaces beyond them so
even those cannot be seen by us
and by looking at the distribution of
light in the sky
we get an idea merely of the size and
shape of our special white space
and if you think that situs is
predicting the existence of black holes
here keep in mind this is 47 years
before the term black hole was even
first used and almost 20 years before
chandrasekhar even theorized the
existence of something like a black hole
he says the boundary surface is between
the positive and negative sections of
space that when light crosses it it
crosses in one direction from the
positive side to the negative side if we
were on the positive side as seems to be
the case then we could not see beyond
such surface
though we might easily have
gravitational or other evidence of
bodies existing beyond the surface and
that seems to have a lot in common with
what we know as the event horizon
cytus then mentions a supernova and
suggests that the flaring up of a star
must be it changing over from the
negative to the positive tendency
that in the universe stars will be
constantly crossing over from one
section to the next and that when this
happens and a star crosses over from a
positive to a negative section of the
universe there happens a slow process of
development of life growth changing the
star from a positive one to a negative
one gradually
and here you can start to see where the
title of this book comes from the
animate and the inanimate
cytus says that inanimate phenomena are
positive tendencies and follow the
second law of thermodynamics
while animate phenomena on the contrary
are negative tendencies and tend to
reverse that law
there's a motivation behind a lot of
these stranger connections which comes
from the fact that at the time this book
was written around 1920 there was a lot
about biology and living processes that
we didn't understand and we have learned
so much more since then
the way that biological processes work
within living bodies and the way that
cells process energy
is much less of a mystery to us now
and a lot of what we know about biology
wouldn't stack up against some of these
claims even the way our own brains work
was a lot less understood cytis calls it
a central organ in which the reserve
energy is stored
and it seems that if he had been raised
in any other family he probably wouldn't
have had that idea and been trying to
draw that kind of a connection
some of the claims get more and more
dubious as the pages go on but cyrus
himself even recognizes this and ends
with some objections to his theory he
emphasizes that this work is only mere
speculation one objection is that we
have no proof that life really does
reverse the second law of thermodynamics
instead we have plenty of evidence of
living bodies obeying the second law the
theory also supposes that life exists
everywhere and under all sorts of
circumstances but that's in contrast to
what we actually observe when it comes
to life it instead seems to be an
extremely complex phenomenon that can
exist only under very special
circumstances
cytus says that he will leave the reader
to compare for themselves the theory and
weigh up the various arguments for and
against this book remained pretty much
unknown for many decades when it was
found again in 1979
it was given to buckminster fuller who
happened to be a former harvard
classmate of william sidis buckminster
fuller gave the work perhaps its first
proper review he said that he felt
excitement and joy on being handed a
copy of the book which he says clearly
predicts the black hole so many people
commenting on sidus's life have said
that he amounted to nothing and didn't
use any of his academic brilliance but
fuller says here i hope you'll become as
excited as i am at this discovery that
cyrus did go on after college to do the
most magnificent thinking and writing
sidus's work is hard to understand and
we may never find a place for it within
modern theories but cyrus himself was
also hard for society to understand
people poked at his first signs of
weakness perhaps to feel better about
themselves
william didn't deserve to be lumped with
the pressures of having to continuously
prove his genius that a child prodigy
would grow up and collapse under the
mental burden of their childhood is an
easier narrative to report on than
understanding the alternative ways that
we all try to live a fulfilling life
this portion of the video is sponsored
by skillshare if you watch this video
then you're probably interested in
examples of exceptional ability and ways
to reach your own potential
if you want to learn from experts and
foster your own skills check out
skillshare which is an online learning
community with thousands of online
classes
it's a place to get inspired learn new
skills and put them to work in impactful
ways
i spent a lot of the last year learning
stop-motion animation for finding x and
this course from pez is a great intro to
the technique coming from one of the
largest stop-motion animators on youtube
there's a special link down in the
description and the first 1000 people to
click it will get a one month free trial
of skillshare so check it out and thank
you for watching
a special shout out to today's patreon
cats of the day
pan and tilt